enter where all the action is happening
yeah i must i must say i just i think
practical terms i hate that decision
swapping rooks because look at this
black's remaining pouring out the pawn
at the top of the board the f7 pawn is
about to get traded off and white still
has a couple of pawns running uh i just
think magnus maybe okay three seconds he
made that move with he might still be
winning but he's made it difficult for
himself keeping the rooks on maybe uh
just slightly more practical and okay
it's one pawn vessel oh look at the bar
that's the thing
oh and magnus reacts has he blundered
the wind you think he's blundered the
wind yeah he absolutely has because now
that white pawn will just run and it can
run for a long time don't run with the
point drop your bishop back attack
black's remaining pawn if the two pawns
get traded off there we go it's a simple
draw white's king coming up and rook
against bishop is a draw
magnus is he even going to try no he
doesn't try and liam escapes it's king
versus king it's a draw
wow